(dramatic music)
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
Thank you, thank you so much.
Your lovely comments, Glenn,
just, I'm so touched by what you said.
Thank you.
Oh my, talk about a change
in pace, what editors can do.
Whew! (laughs)
Now, (breathes deeply) ah.
You always say to breathe, right?
- [Audience Member] Breathe!
- I first met Glenn at the start
of the ensemble cast
rehearsal for "The Big Chill,"
on location in Beaufort, South Carolina,
before principal photography started.
Can you believe such a crazy notion?
Larry Kasdan asked me to
attend the actors' rehearsals
where I became a fly on the wall,
watching and listening
to the actors' process.
Glenn was responsible for teaching me
the key lesson of editing,
to interpret the actors' work
within a dynamic of the ensemble
to heighten and hone the
experience incrementally
for the audience.
I was able to watch her hard work,
the distillation of
character and relationships
grow naturally without effort.
And for that, Glenn,
for that fundamental lesson of simplicity,
my north star for over 40 years,
I am eternally grateful.
(audience applauding)
- Woo!
(Carol chuckling)
It was an extraordinary experience.
Well, this is the beginning
my adventure in film,
back as a kid in rural Oklahoma,
where I grew up in a
small town on Route 66.
In the 1940s, my hometown
had three walk-in theaters,
the Coleman, a beautiful movie palace,
now beautifully restored,
and the now-shuttered
Ottawa and the Glory B,
where my sister and I
attended the kiddie matinee every Saturday
with our little outfits,
our Western outfits,
cowboy boots, hat, jeans,
and two shiny quarters in our pocket
to cover the price of admission
for three hours of
uninterrupted entertainment,
starting with 20 minutes of cartoons,
two serials, usually episodes
of "Hopalong Cassidy,"
"Flash Gordon," or "Captain America,"
the Western, of the
singing cowboy variety,
starring Roy Rogers and
Dale Evans or Gene Autry,
and once in a while,
a movie about my favorite
Ozark hillbillies,
Ma and Pa Kettle.
- Woo!
(audience laughing)
- At an Oscar event, way!
- Woo!
- Kids without adults had
unbridled freedom to laugh
and shout and make believe in total chaos.
It was fantastic. I loved it.
Flash forward from Miami,
Oklahoma, not Miami, Florida,
to Paris, where I spent
my junior year abroad.
When I arrived, I barely
spoke the language
and I needed a shortcut for
learning colloquial French.
So here's the secret.
Watch en version originale,
an American film with French subtitles.
And not only that, I got to discover
the classic Western at
the Cinematheque Francais,
"Beautiful World of John
Ford," at a retrospective.
"She Wore a Yellow Ribbon," "Ford Apache,"
"My Darling Clementine," "Stagecoach,"
and "The Searchers."
My adventure in film
continued that same summer
when I met a lanky student in
Florence, Italy, John Bailey.
(audience applauding)
(laughs) Thank you.
Little did I know that
John would change my life,
lure me to Los Angeles,
where we would marry and
share a life in film,
working our way through the
ranks, learning on the job,
helping and supporting each other.
We were lucky to work
on 12 films together.
I thank Lawrence Kasdan, Jonathan Demme,
and Ken Kwapis,
who understood the value
of our dual collaboration,
and I thank them deeply
and forever for that gift.
Larry. (laughs)
(audience applauding)
There are always perplexing moments
during the editorial process.
We had one such crucial moment
during the editing of "E.T."
when we suffered the
equivalent of writers block.
I guess we called it editors blank.
Steven had the brilliant idea
to cook Matzo Brei for
the entire editorial crew.
(audience laughing)
Delicious. Problem solved.
I promised I would never
disclose his recipe,
his secret recipe for success
but if you take The New York Times,
look at the cooking app,
I think you'll find the secret there.
(audience laughing)
when I think about the privilege I had
to work on one of the most
entertaining, enduring,
and endearing films of all time,
I'm frequently asked,
"Why do you think 'E.T.'
is a perennial favorite?"
There are so many
reasons, but fundamentally
it's its powerful story about
tolerance for the other.
Elliott, Michael, and
Gertie learn to trust
and love the alien among them.
With a little humidity.
Excuse me. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
With a little humility and patience,
we too can find our common
humanity in uncommon places.
This Oscar is the Everest
moment of my adventure in film,
a dream fulfilled,
and I wanna thank the Governors
of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences.
I accept this beautiful Oscar
as a highlight of my life in film.
I accept it for all editors
who toil in the darkness
of an editing room,
weighing each cut, making infinite choices
to create a unique, believable world
borne of the imagination.
And most of all, I want to
thank John, my dear Johnny.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Woo!
(dramatic music)